[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEFF DEAN: All
right, thanks Zach.
And thank you all for
coming, and welcome everyone
on the livesteam.
We're really, really excited
about the TensorFlow developer
summit.
So when we open sourced
TensorFlow about a little bit
more than a year
ago, we really were
hoping to build a
machine learning platform
for everyone in the world.
It's very clear that
machine learning
is going to be
incredibly important
across many, many different
kinds of applications
and problem domains across
many fields of science,
across many industries.
And we wanted to build an open
source platform that everyone
could share and could contribute
to that was fast, flexible,
and production-ready.
And that's really the
kind of three mantras
that we've been
working towards as we
continue to evolve TensorFlow.
But first, a bit of history.
So our group has been doing
deep learning research for about
five, five and a half years.
And the first system we
built was called Disbelief.
And this was a system
that worked well for us
in our early work in this area.
So we published a paper
about Disbelief in NIPS 2012,
it was well received.
Disbelief had a lot of
really nice properties.
It was very scalable,
so we could train models
in very large
numbers of computers,
we could train very
large, powerful models.
We did a lot of
interesting work with that,
and so did other
people at Google,
including some of the
early inception image
work, a lot of work with
our speech recognition team
to improve our speech
recognition systems,
work with our search team to
improve our search ranking
system by deploying neural nets
in the middle of the search
stack.
But ultimately we realized
that Disbelief was not
really exactly what
we wanted as we
got more experience
with applying
these kinds of problems.
It was designed for
CPUs because that's
what we had in our data
centers when we first
started this work.
GPU support was added
later, but it was kind of
bolted onto the side.
It wasn't really thought through
as much as we would have liked.
And the system
worked really well
if what you wanted to express
worked in the programming model
that Disbelief had.
But if you wanted to do
something a little bit
outside of what it was
originally designed for,
it was a little bit
hard, especially
for research purposes.
So what we wanted to
do with TensorFlow
is take a step back and redesign
what we had with Disbelief,
and keep the nice
properties of Disbelief,
but make it more flexible
and more general purpose.
And so TensorFlow really
takes the scalable properties
that Disbelief had and
the production readiness,
but then extends it to be much
more flexible for research.
And so we really want to scan
this whole continuum of really
flexible ideas, and then
being able to take those ideas
and put them all the
way into production
without having to go into
a new kind of system.
So that's why we
built TensorFlow,
and we wanted to open source it
so that everyone in the world
could actually use it.
We also felt it was really
important to support
many platforms.
Disbelief was really
designed mostly
for data center applications,
but obviously mobile platforms
are really important, being
able to run workloads on CPUs,
and GPUs, and custom
accelerators like PPUs
that Google has, and
that other startup
companies and large companies
are developing in this space
as machine learning acceleration
becomes more important.
And running on a variety
of mobile platforms.
Android and iOS support
and Raspberry Pi support
have been added in
TensorFlow because we
want to be able to take
models and run them wherever
machine learning needs occur.
And we also want to be able
to run on cloud platforms.
So you can run this on Google
Cloud or other cloud systems
using TensorFlow
running in raw VMs.
Google Cloud also has a
high level cloud machine
merging service that is
more of a managed service
where you can run TensorFlow.
And so TensorFlow works really
well on Google Cloud, as well.
And we wanted to add
support for other languages.
So when we initially released
TensorFlow we had Python
and c++ support.
And over time we and
others in the community
have added other language
bindings and other higher
level language support so
that different languages can
access the power of TensorFlow.
We've also worked
pretty hard on making it
so that we can have
good visualization tools
and monitoring tools for
machine learning, training,
and inference so that you
can really understand what
it is your models are doing.
Really getting a
good sense of what's
happening in those
processes allows researchers
to be more productive,
and to really
dive into what's going on.
So we've had a lot
of progress to date,
so I'll just highlight
some of that.
So the area to the left is
mostly our Disbelief system,
and we use that for a
variety of different things.
But you can really
see within Google
that as we released
TensorFlow internally,
and then eventually as an open
source product, that we've
been able to have
many, many more people
and more teams at Google
use machine learning,
and use TensorFlow to
improve both our products,
so it's integrated into many
features in search, and Gmail,
and translating maps,
and many other things,
but also to use it
for research use.
So we've done
hundreds of projects
that use TensorFlow,
published hundreds of papers
using TensorFlow as the
basis for our machine
learning research.
And it's also now the number
one repository in machine
learning category on GitHub.
So we're pretty
excited about that.
It's been really well received
in the external community.
And you can see that
TensorFlow adoption has really
accelerated quite quickly.
And I think that's
testament to the community
that we've started to build
and are continuing to build,
where lots of people are
contributing to TensorFlow
and using it for all kinds
of interesting and innovative
ways.
We have almost 500
non-google contributors
have contributed
code to TensorFlow.
We have about 1,000 commits per
month in the source code base.
Many, many people
outside in the community
have created tutorials,
and other kinds of model
implantations and
TensorFlow translations
of the documentation,
interesting projects.
There's about 5,500
GitHub repositories now
with TensorFlow in the
title, only four or five
of which are the
official repositories.
And we've had a lot of direct
engagement with this community
by answering questions
on Stack Overflow
dealing with issue
and feature requests
that people have submitted.
And one of the things
we're really happy to see
is that the use in
machine learning classes
is starting to happen in
different universities.
So Toronto, Berkeley, and
Stanford, for example,
are all using TensorFlow as
the basis of important machine
learning classes in
their curriculum.
Since we launched, we've been
adding features and working
with the community
to understand what
features are really important
that they want to see.
And just to highlight
a few, TensorFlow
distributed training support
was added a few months
after our initial launch.
Various high level
APIs have been
added so that people
can more easily express
the kinds of models
they want without having
to necessarily specify things
that are very low level.
Things like TensorFlow Slim.
We've added Windows
support, and for example,
HTFS support, support for
CUDA [INAUDIBLE] and CuDNN.
Many, many things here that the
community has been asking for
have made it into
different releases,
and we've kept up about a
release every couple of months
cadence.
Minor release.
And all of this has happened
in just over a year.
So this is pretty amazing.
This community is really
vibrant and thriving.
I'm really excited to be part
of a big open source project.
A lot of the work that I've
done in Google in the past
has been not open
souce projects,
and it's really nice to
see the external usage
of the TensorFlow system, and
what people are doing with it.
I'm going to invite Rajat Monga,
our TensorFlow engineering
lead, up to talk about
what's new today.
Thank you.
RAJAT MONGA: Thank you, Jeff.
Hello, everyone.
So there are lots of
amazing announcements today.
And let's get started.
Let me start with the first
one and the most exciting one.
Today we are excited to
announce TensorFlow 1.0.
Jeff talked about a number of
things that have come together
to really get us to 1.0.
And before I get into more
of the things, the new things
that we're announcing
today, let's
take a moment to just thank
all the wonderful people who
have made this happen.
So kudos to an amazing team
that's come together to make
TensorFlow a great product.
Thanks to all of
you, the community,
who's really gotten together.
There are nearly
500 contributors,
as Jeff mentioned, from outside
Google who've contributed code
back to TensorFlow.
And the many others on
Stack Overflow and GitHub
who are helping with issues,
and support, and so on.
So thank you all.
Let's get started, let's
take a look at what's
there in TensorFlow 1.0.
It's fast.
Performance has always
been important to us.
It's one of the
things that's really
helped deep learning
get to where
it is to give the great
results that it's been getting.
And today with 1.0 we're showing
a 58X speed up on 64 GPUs
running the inception
v3, which is
one of the great benchmarks
for image performance.
It's flexible.
Jeff mentioned some of
the high level APIs,
we're announcing even more.
We want to make it easy for
you to do all the things.
TensorFlow's
philosophy has always
been to give you the power
to do whatever you want,
but also make it easy, and
this makes it even easier.
And it's production-ready.
With 1.0 and semantic
versioning that will follow,
we're guaranteeing that we'll
ensure backwards compatibility
for all future changes.
So as you get new
versions and new features,
you don't have to worry
about breaking things.
And many more as some of the
guests later will talk about.
But let's take a look
at some of these.
Let's start at the
high level APIs.
One of our goals has
always been to bring
machine learning to everyone.
And these high level APIs
really make it easier,
and hopefully will
get to more people.
So let's take a look
at what they are.
This is a picture
that's probably
familiar to a lot of you if
you've been using TensorFlow.
In the middle is the core
distributed execution engine
written in c++ for
high performance.
It abstracts away
all the various kinds
of devices, some of which
Jeff showed earlier,
like CPUs, GPUs, and so on.
And does a great job at that.
On top of it are the
various languages,
like the Python front
and the c++ front.
And again, many
different languages that
are being supported there.
Now today we're announcing
a number of APIs
on top of the Python front end.
The first one is layers.
So these allow really, if you're
using deep learning models,
to build fully connected
convolution pooling and all
the standard layers
that you come up
with as pre-built components so
you don't have to really start
making them from scratch.
Again, making it easier for you.
On top of that, Keras is
an API that a lot of you
are probably familiar with.
It's pretty popular.
And we are announcing
the integration of Keras
with TensorFlow,
and implementation
to make it, again, easier
to build those models.
And an estimated API that really
helps you take those models,
combine them with your
data sets, et cetera,
make it easy for you to train
and evaluate these models.
And finally, on top
of all of these,
there are a number of models
that are already there
for you in the box for you.
For example, linear regression,
simple DNNs, and so on,
that you can start with
that you can actually
run on your core to train stuff
with very few lines of code.
Next up, so
TensorFlow's is always
done great in deep learning,
but we built the core
to be really
flexible to allow you
to do all kinds of
amazing things with it.
And today we are
announcing broad machine
learning support with the help
of many teams across Google
and folks externally, as well.
So let's take a look at
everything that we are doing.
Of course as with
everything else,
performance is
important for these.
So all of these implementations
are pretty fast,
and you can take advantage
of them on a single machine
or distributed in a cluster.
If you're trying
to do clustering,
K-means is an
obvious choice, so we
have an implementation of
K-means in TensorFlow for you.
If you're doing classification,
support vector machines
are used often.
And this might be a great place
to start, especially if you
have predefined features.
But then going from there,
if you want to, let's say,
learn features or do something
fancier, the same kind of APIs
are there for you to try deep
learning or other algorithms
as well.
We also have decision
trees and random forests,
again for classification
and regression.
And many, many more.
Ashish will be talking
more and in more
detail about these later today.
Let's look at some new
platforms and accelerators.
Jeff showed a whole
number of bunch of them
that were there earlier.
I'm just going to mention a
few that we've added recently.
TensorFlow's included in
IBM's PowerAI distribution.
IBM announced this
pretty recently.
So if you're using IBM power
systems for deep learning,
now there's a
software package that
includes TensorFlow to give you
high performance and the ease
of use that you
would like there.
It's also supported
by accelerators
such as the Movidius
Myriad 2 accelerator.
This can be used for
embedded platforms.
It takes the TensorFlow
modeling and really
allows you to run that
efficiently on these chips.
And most recently, there's been
support for Qualcomm's Hexagon
DSP.
And to talk about
that, I would like
to welcome Travis Lanier
who's here with us
from Qualcomm today.
Travis is senior product
managing director at Qualcomm.
TRAVIS LANIER: Thank you.
We're very excited
to have collaborated
with Google to optimize
TensorFlow for Hexagon DSP.
If you take a look at this
little video we have looping up
here, you can see about
an 8x performance increase
by moving it from
the CPU to the DSP.
And keep in mind, this is
happening with a mobile phone's
power profile.
So this is very power
efficient, really high
power processing
compared to what
you've been able to
see for these type
neural tasks on a mobile phone.
Now the good news is
that we've already
done the optimization for you.
So if you have a TensorFlow
model and you move it over,
you should be able to see a
similar type of performance
uplift on our Hexagon DSP.
We will be open sourcing this
software, including the driver,
and it'll be available on our
Dragonboard 820 development
platform.
Thank you.
RAJAT MONGA: Thank you, Travis.
So Pete Warden will be
talking in more detail
about our support for
mobile and embedded.
It's clearly very,
very important,
and you can see more in
his talk later today.
So we care about
performance in many ways.
You've seen some of those areas.
As you think of TensorFlow
as a programming languages
here building these
amazing models,
what better way to look at
performance than the compiler
compilation techniques?
So today we are
announcing XLA, which
is an experimental
TensorFlow compiler.
It's really built
for TensorFlow,
so a compiler for TensorFlow.
XLA stands for accelerator
linear algebra,
basically accelerates
the kinds of models
you make with TensorFlow.
It basically takes a graph
and compiles that down
to assembly code for
the architecture that
matters to you for the kind
of chip that you are running.
And it can be used for
just in time compilation,
for example in
training workloads,
et cetera, whether
in the data center
or elsewhere, and also for
ahead of time compilation
where it just takes the graphs,
compiles it down to code,
and then you can
just ship the code
and not worry about
anything else.
Again, Chris and Todd
will be talking about it
later this morning, so
there's a lot more there.
And with that, I
would like to welcome
Megan Kacholia, engineering
director at Brain who's
been leading our
performance efforts to talk
about TensorFlow in depth.
MEGAN KACHOLIA: Thanks, Rajat.
I want to start just by diving
a bit more into performance.
So as we've talked
about, TensorFlow
is really made for the
community at large.
And that spans a lot
of different use cases,
whether you're looking at things
from the research perspective
or thinking about just
production environments
and what that means.
On the research side, being
able to have performance
improvements, get more and more
performance out of TensorFlow
and out of the machines
you're using underneath it
gives you a lot of flexibility.
Whether it's want to
iterate more quickly,
you want to train
models faster, maybe
you want to run more
experiments in parallel.
So it's very
important for us to be
able to continue to improve
on performance to provide
that flexibility on
the research side.
But we don't want to forget
about the production side,
as well.
And for production there's,
again, many different use
cases.
Whether you're looking at
large scale server farms,
or also thinking about
embedded use cases
like we've talked about.
Whether it's on device,
running on a mobile device,
or some other kind
of smaller device
that has a special setup.
And again, even
then we're thinking
about lots of different
types of hardware,
and low latency serving
is also part of this.
I think a lot of times
people think of TensorFlow
and they think of just
the training perspective,
but we've done a lot of
work in open-source things
through our initial
releases that provide
ways of serving as well.
This is low latency
serving that you
can use in a production setup.
But what good is it to
talk about performance
without actually
looking at numbers?
So this is just a
little setup first.
Let me explain some of this.
So what we're
looking at here is we
have revised our implementation
of the Inception v3 model,
and we're currently working
on open sourcing that,
and we'll have that
out in a few weeks.
But all of the graphs shown
here are using that model
under the covers.
And then we're looking across
two different machine types.
So we've done some benchmarking
on the NVIDIA DGX-1, a very,
very powerful
machine, so that we
can see how TensorFlow
really scales when you are
using much, much faster GPUs.
And also looking at K80s, since
those are much more widely
available, especially
in all the various cloud
computing platforms
that are out there.
And this is just
the ideal scaling.
So let's see how
TensorFlow stacks up.
So the first thing
we're looking at
is, again, looking at training
this Inception v3 model
with synthetic data.
I think the really
cool thing to call out
here is that even when
you're moving from a K80
to a much more powerful
machine like a DGX-1,
you're still seeing
impressive scaling
numbers across the eight
GPUs that we're showing here.
But it's not good to just
look at synthetic data.
I know that's what is
generally used for benchmarking
in the industry,
but we also want
to understand, how
do things actually
perform with real data?
Since that's what
I'm assuming people
are actually using for
building their models,
and running their
production setup,
and doing their research.
So let's plop that
in there, as well.
Now you can see even when
you move from synthetic data
to real data, the scaling
is still very impressive.
And TensorFlow is scaling
well across the eight GPUs
here, whether you're looking
at a powerful DGX-1 setup
or you're looking at
something like a K80, as well.
But it's not just about
the single machine setups,
we also need to think about
distributed performance.
And for distributed
performance as well, we've
been doing a lot of work to
improve that, and improve
our scaling to make sure that,
again, whatever machinery
you have and that
you want to be using,
TensorFlow can make
the most use of it
and be able to give
you whatever benefits
and flexibility you need.
So here we're showing a 58x
speed up across 64 GPUs.
This is the number that
Rajat quoted as well
when we were talking about
the TensorFlow 1.0 release.
So I think it's really exciting,
just all of the improvements
that we've made on the
performance side of things,
and all the flexibility
and the options
that it gives back
to the community.
Now I want to go
just a little bit
into examples on the
research and the production
side of things.
So neural machine translation
as a common example we've
talked about a lot.
So here you can see with the
old phrase-based model, which
actually had
hundreds of thousands
of lines of hand-tuned code.
When we moved that to a
neural model in TensorFlow,
we're actually able to
see huge improvements
across various language pairs,
in some cases reducing errors
by up to 85%.
Here's a slightly
more fun example.
It's a little interesting
to look at this graph.
But this is neural
architecture search,
where you're
essentially building
a neural network in TensorFlow
that can figure out,
what is the right
under the covers
neural architecture to
use for solving a problem?
And it's great to see these
cutting-edge research cases
also being done in TensorFlow.
And here's another example
that has been open-sourced
by Google Research.
So looking at things
like captioning images.
And it's not just about
providing a caption for it,
it's providing a
human-sounding caption for it.
So it's very impressive to
combine this type of language
understanding and also
applying that with the images
and doing that in TensorFlow.
But again, it's not
just about research.
We also need to look at
different types of production
use cases, as well.
And it's important
to, again, remember
that TensorFlow, when we talk
about production use cases,
we're talking about both
the training side of things,
and also using TensorFlow
for low latency serving.
A cool example here is
something like Word Lens.
So this is something where, a
lot of times when people think
about production use cases, they
think about large data centers.
But a lot of
production use cases
these days are actually apps.
You release an
app, it's actually
running on someone's device.
So here's an example
with Word Lens,
where it's combining translation
and vision, essentially,
and actually running
on the device
using TensorFlow to
be able to provide you
what that sign might look
like in a different language.
And of course at
Google, we make a lot
of use of tons of TensorFlow
and deep learning.
So we talked about
translate a lot.
There are other
examples, like using it
in Gmail for spam
detection, using it
in Street View for understanding
signs, street sign recognition.
And also using it in,
perhaps, the Google Play
Store for app recommendations.
But while it's great that
there's so many use cases
internally at Google,
that's not really
the whole point of TensorFlow.
The point of TensorFlow
is to figure out,
how can we give this
back to the community
and make it so that everyone can
be making use of deep learning
and be able to use
TensorFlow to further,
whether is the research
or the production needs?
So it's great to have such
a large list of companies
that are actually making
use of TensorFlow as well.
So we've already
heard from Qualcomm
stepping up, will be other
things that will be mentioned
throughout the day, as well.
But we really want
to make sure we're
engaging with the community,
understanding what
the needs are so that over time
this list of other folks who
are using TensorFlow
in their own use cases
will continue to grow.
And with that, I'd like to
hand it back off to Jeff
to talk a bit more
about what's ahead.
JEFF DEAN: Thank you, Megan.
So I think one of
the things that's
great about the community
is that TensorFlow is really
for everyone.
And some of the
things that people
have done with TensorFlow are
things that we would never
have thought of.
Because really, people
have their own problems,
and they're using TensorFlow
in very creative ways.
So you may have seen this
story a few months ago
of this Japanese cucumber
farmer and his wife
and their son, who happens to be
an automotive embedded systems
engineer.
And every harvest
season, the wife
would spend a lot of
time sorting cucumbers.
Because you need to sort them
for market into big ones,
small ones, curved
ones, not curved ones.
And so they rigged up a
system using a Raspberry
Pi and a camera and
TensorFlow to essentially
sort the cucumbers automatically
into the right shapes.
And so this is a creative
use of TensorFlow
that we would not
have thought of.
It's really cool that
people are finding
really neat uses for it.
And now there's not
a lot of human labor
that needs to be done to
sort these cucumbers, which
doesn't sound like a
very interesting task.
Another area we're
really excited about
is the applications of
machine learning for medicine.
And our group has
been doing some work
on the diagnosis of
diabetic retinopathy
using computer vision.
So the task here is essentially
to take a retinal image
like this-- you go to
the ophthalmologist,
they typically take
an image like this.
And then the ophthalmologist
looks at this
to see if there are any early
signs of diabetic retinopathy.
And this is really important.
Because if you catch this
disease early enough,
it's very treatable.
But if you don't, it's
actually the leading cause
of blindness in the world.
And so we now have a
system in an article that
was published in the "Journal
of the American Medical
Association" by
people in our group
that shows that a computer
vision model trained
on the right kind
of data can actually
be as good, or slightly better
than the median ophthalmologist
at diagnosing
diabetic retinopathy.
And this is really
important, because [MIC CUT]
to the world--
and what's really
lacking is access
to ophthalmologists to
actually interpret the images.
And so this can really
help increase access.
There's other uses
in medicine, as well.
So I'd like to invite Brett
Coprell from Stanford.
He's a Stanford PhD student
in the EE department,
and he's been doing
some really nice work
on dermatology assessment with
the computer vision models.
Thanks, Brett.
BRETT COPRELL: Hey, everyone.
I'm Brett Coprell.
My colleagues and I at
Stanford have trained a model
using TensorFlow to classify
images of dangerous skin
lesions.
We're thrilled to have achieved
dermatologist-level performance
at recognizing melanoma and
other types of skin cancer.
At a sensitivity of
98%, we're 90% specific.
I look forward to sharing the
details with you during my talk
later today.
And if you have a copy of
"Nature," I'm happy to sign it.
JEFF DEAN: Very good,
all right, thank you.
Thank you, Brett.
The cover article in
"Nature" is like the kind
of really pillar of achievement
in the field of science,
so this is really
fantastic work.
And we actually had a
corkboard outside the venue
here today to talk about
other kinds of creative uses
that people are
doing for TensorFlow,
and I just picked a couple.
So continuing on
the medical theme,
one group is doing
classification and clustering
of MRI based brain networks to
diagnose psychiatric disorders
and plan treatment.
So that's pretty cool.
And another one is
doing a painting robot,
which sounds pretty cool also.
So I think it's just really nice
to see all the creative uses
that the community is making
for putting TensorFlow to use
in solving their
problems, and also
that the community is
contributing to improving
the base core TensorFlow.
So we're really excited
to have everyone here,
both in person and
on the livestream
for our first
TensorFlow dev summit.
And we want to see all the
amazing things that you
guys can do with TensorFlow.
So thank you very much.
ZAK STONE: It's been
just over a year
since we open
sourced TensorFlow,
and we've been thrilled
to see the adoption
by the community and
the pace of development,
both here at Google and
all around the world.
JEFF DEAN: TensorFlow is
really the primary tool
that we're using for
a lot of our machine
learning work in
all of our products.
Toward the end of
last year, we actually
rolled out a completely
new translation system that
was based on deep neural nets.
In Gmail, we were actually able
to roll out a TensorFlow model
that, by understanding
the context of the message
you just received, we can
predict likely replies
and this is a feature
we call Smart Reply.
LILY PENG: Diabetic retinopathy
is the fastest growing cause
of blindness.
It's a complication of diabetes.
We gathered a very
large data set
and had doctors
grade the images.
And then we, using TensorFlow,
trained a neural net
that does a pretty good job
of predicting whether or not
there is diabetic
retinopathy in the image.
DOUG ECK: Can we use something
like TensorFlow to make music,
to make art, and to allow
us to communicate better
with each other?
With TensorFlow, we're
able to think abstractly,
almost at a level of
like improvisation
with machine learning.
We're able to try new
things, to chunk models
together in ways that
were impossible before we
had that kind of expressivity.
AMANDA HODGSON:
Dugongs are classed
as vulnerable to
extinction globally.
So we do a lot of aerial
surveys using drones.
Then once you've done a
survey of a really large area,
you end up with tens, if
not hundreds of thousands
of photos.
The goal was to find a way to
automate that whole process.
And that's where we've
been using TensorFlow.
ZAK STONE: One of
the things that we've
been focusing on this year
with TensorFlow is performance.
We've been especially
excited to release support
for distributed training.
MEGAN KACHOLIA:
We want to make it
easier for people to use so they
don't have to necessarily know
all of the underlying internals
in order to get the distributed
performance the best it can be.
[INAUDIBLE] is something that
can compile down TensorFlow.
Maybe you want to compile
your graph ahead of time
and get it down to
something much more compact
in terms of memory size, so
that that way you can easily
load it and execute it on
something that might not
have as much storage
space, like a mobile phone,
or some other portable,
smaller device.
RICK MAULE: When we introduced
the Hexagon vector extensions,
what we had in mind was
enhancing user experiences
with imaging features.
ERICH PLONDKE: So
the TensorFlow team
said that you only needed
low precision multipliers
to be able to execute these
neural networks efficiently.
So we did some tests, and on the
same graph, Inception section
v3, we were eight times
faster and four times lower
power than running on the CPUs.
RICK MAULE: TensorFlow
is great to work
with, easy to work with,
lots of capability.
So our engineering teams
and their engineering teams
working together, we were able
to do something very exciting.
This is just the
beginning of what
will end up being a long
evolution of some great things
we can do with machine
learning and image processing.
JOSH GORDON: In addition
to sharing TensorFlow,
Google has also
shared a ecosystem
of tools, which
contains everything
you need to go all the way
from research to production.
One such tool is
TensorFlow Serving,
and this is a open source, high
performance serving solution.
Another great tool, which
is actually quite beautiful,
is the embedding visualizer.
And you can use the
embedding visualizer
to interactively explore
high dimensional data sets.
On the education
side, General Assembly
has done great work
teaching TensorFlow.
NEHEMIAH LOURY: For
my final project,
I was really interested in
doing lyrics generation.
And TensorFlow was a really
great match for that,
because it allowed me to build
out and utilize the models
that I needed to be successful.
ZAK STONE: The
TensorFlow community
is thriving around
the world, and we're
excited about as many people
as possible being part of it.
TensorFlow is an open
source project for everyone.
We're looking forward
to building this
into something even better, and
more useful, and more powerful
in collaboration with the
whole worldwide community.